that was so long ago it's like
[Music]
gosh I'm so old uh I first got online in
1994 when I was in the Army has already
journalist oh and I'm a gentleman
yeah and I think the first websites I
ever went to I think it would I can be
to one liz'
it was like a Simpsons fansite I was
like a message board where people just
talking about the Simpsons and I was
like told I was a big Simpsons man so I
went that's just reading about the
Simpsons of other people and back before
the internet if bands didn't put lyrics
on albums you didn't know what the hell
they were saying and so I grew up in the
punk rock scene where you couldn't hear
half of what people were screaming
anyway and so the other website I went
to first website I went to was a site
that just posted lyrics from bands I
liked and I went just literally went
just to print out lyrics for my favorite
songs so I could sing them like my
favorite songs so I could finally sing
what the hell they were saying and not
what I thought they were saying and and
you realize like I was sorry that yeah
those walls have completely and totally
broken down if you're under the age of
40 and if you're over the age of 40
anyway but yeah these are not saying the
era of like being bullied or made fun of
or look down upon from playing or being
into video games or internet culture in
general or even comic books at this
point is just completely and totally
gone it's funny every thing about my
childhood that I liked I was derided and
made fun of and tortured and bullied for
and every one of those things that every
one of those kids bullied me for they
and their kids are next to me at the
movie theater watching The Avengers yeah
and they are watching the kid play for
tonight yeah and I think it's cool yeah
everything I thought was awesome in 1985
is
officers took the world 30 years to
catch her I read comic books religiously
from the age of six to about 35
specifically Marvel DC mostly in a
Marvel and I was a huge x-men fan from I
never got super in the DC but I was a
big vertigo thing
I think it's really sad that anonymity
has emboldened people to cruelty yeah
but at the same time having been in this
career and it may come from the fact
that I've been doing this for over 15
years now and we have from day one had a
relationship in a conversation with our
audience that's fairly intimate and and
honest and so they have been very honest
with me over the years I think I've
developed a pretty thick skin and I
think to be in this industry you just
need to and that I'm not excusing online
trolls or any of those people that
torture and torment and bullied online
it's terrible
I mean it's atrocious but if you're
gonna put yourself out in the public eye
you need to be receptive to the fact
that you're gonna receive criticism and
you we all have it we get so caught up
in social media yeah we get so caught up
and what's somebody on reddit or on
Twitter is saying about us and you let
like a negative comment on Twitter like
a shitty tweet or a flippant comment on
youtube or on our website from somebody
who just devalue something you did or is
rude or says like wow just good going on
lit just 43 going on 53 you know or any
of that stuff it can you know we have to
remember that we we can stop all of that
just by not looking at ya you know like
you have the ability to turn all of it
off just by doing this just to get rid
of all of that cuz yeah yeah it's
self-imposed there we go and it like you
go you all like I I'm I fall prey to
that too you do something that you think
is really funny and maybe you should
make a joke in an episode or you make a
show that you think is gonna be really
funny and you immediately go to the
internet to see the comments on it if
you want you want to make sure you're on
the right track you want to make sure
you're you want to make sure that your
creating something that resonates with
the audience the people enjoy and and
there might be a thousand comments about
how great it is and if you see 15 that
say it's terrible that's all you see and
that's all you think about and the other
thousand comments might as well not
exist because you are so laser focused
on that the ten [ __ ] then it
probably didn't even watch it you know
just no no and there's always
constructive criticism in there as well
and you take that too but you really
just like at the end of the day the
thing that you go to bed at night the
last thing you think about is that guy
calling you fat or you know whatever
there are a million things that apply
that I would say for broadband internet
was the moment when independent online
creators like ourselves could service a
global community in an efficient and
accessible way so I would say it's at
the birth of rocket you know once we got
past dial-up when we made red vs. blue
we put up first episode of Everest blue
in April of 2003 you couldn't watch a
video in a browser you had to download
and play through real player or whatever
I mean I guess you could watch flash in
a browser but that wasn't it and so and
if you wanted to download an episode of
Everest blue it was a while like I
remember we had a soldier who I was
talking to an event one time and he said
I was I was deployed in Afghanistan and
I was literally my unit we were
literally in a cave and once a day a
satellite pass over us and we had an
hour of internet and we would download
all the work stuff as soon as possible
so that we can begin the process of
trying to download an episode of red
versus blue because and we would be like
you know we got 45 minutes I hope it's
enough to download this three and a half
minute video I was miserable
put some work into being a fan of
sleeping back in those days you had to
put it with effort you had to you had to
lock down your phone or cell like all
right well I'll watch like everyone
watching we we all worked at this tech
support company Bernie and Gus and I
guys that started rich teeth or somebody
got storage teeth and when the Phantom
Menace trailer came out the company's
shut down for like two hours we were
just watching a progress bar so we could
download the trailer off Apple movies so
that we could watch it you know that
took like we were an Internet company
and it's like a screen a half hours to
download it two and a half minute
trailer I remember that was the big that
was the big like holy [ __ ] everybody
stop what you're doing
there's a new star there's a Star Wars
trailer chrissake
and we can download it on the Internet
eventually and watch it
yeah I would I would make everyone on
the Internet
have an identity associated to their
real life persona and I would strip a
nativity off the internet